[BACKGROUND MUSIC]
This is Cozmo.
He is a cute little robot with a big brain and an even bigger personality and was born to play.
So, a couple of months ago, a company called Anki reach out asking if they could send me this little guy to see what I thought.
So, I brought him to Hawaii with me and we've been hanging out long enough that I've got a pretty good feel for who he is and what he can do.
Now, for decades, we've seen charismatic robots come to life in Hollywood films but, today we've never actually seen them some to life in the real world.
That is until Anki created Cozmo.
This little guy is charming, unpredictable, a bit mischievous, and even recognizes and remembers your name.
Cosmo: Grant.
He also loves playing games.
He's like a super computer on threads, completely self aware and constantly scanning his environment, learning about our world as he goes.
So, when I first took Cosmo out of his package, I wasn't exactly sure what to expect but, the setup couldn't have been any simpler.
The charger takes him from empty to full in only about 10 minutes and gives him around 1 to 2 hours of energy.
He's got his own secure WiFi and when you first plug him in, his head pops up with the password you need to connect.
Now, I went to the play store and found the app by typing in "Cozmo Robot", then connected to Cozmo's WiFi by adjusting the settings on my smart phone.
From here, it was as simple as going back to the app and hitting "connect".
This is the first moment we first woke Cozmo up and brought him to life.
If you watch his face here, you can see he's kind of like a little animal, completely self aware, but, a little intimidated by his new surroundings.
Of course, it doesn't take him long, though, before he's all over the place, checking everything out.
[COZMO MOANS]
Grant: Woah!
[COZMO MOANING AND MAKING NOISES]
Grant: That's awesome.
Grant's child: Yay!
His expressions and body languages are so life like and he's so interactive that it makes him feel like he's real.
So, decided to introduce him to my kids.
Grant: Woah!
Grant's child: Woah!
Grant: He's fiesty!
Grant's child: What the? He wants to put it on me.
4 to 4. Next point wins. Watch the cube. Get it!
Grant: Yeah!
Cozmo's pack full of so much artificial intelligence that he's got the ability to express hundreds of emotions and and react to your feelings and actions as well.
The more you play with him, the better he gets to know you and his personality will constantly evolve as well.
For example, it's quite a challenge to beat him at quick tap anymore because he's gotten better and adapted to how fast I play.
Keep away is another one of my favorite games to play because it's a constant adrenaline rush.
You have to pull a power block away before Cozmo can hit it, but, he's very sneaky and amazingly quick.
This is kind of an intense game actually.
There's also a cool explorer mode where you can look through Cozmo's eyes and guide him by remote control all over the house.
He's also stronger than he looks and very secure.
He's been drop tested for durability and uses a local device to device connection meaning there's no data to be stored in the cloud.
With clever facial expressions and retaining body language and the cutest voice, it's like Cozmo rolled right out of a movie screen and right into our lives.
So, there you have it guys. This is Cozmo.
An awesome little robot buddy, that will fit right into the palm of your hand.
And for the amount of technology and engineering that went into creating him, it doesn't cost that much either.
About $180.
He's the best kind of pet for me and my kids because he doesn't need to be fed and he probably won't pee on the carpet either.
If you want to learn more about Cozmo or get one for yourself, than click the link in the description and it will take you right to him.
Hey, thanks for joining me in this video. I will be looking for you in the next one. Talk to you then.
Grant: Oh! He knocked over my camera! That's funny!